mes célébrations de noël ont débuté ce
soir pour les chrétiens orthodoxes cette
année encore les russes assisteront à la
messe de minuit mais devront elles se
plier aux règles sanitaires plus de
détails avec notre correspondante à
moscou maëlys d'estrées
bonsoir malice vous êtes donc devant la
cathédrale du christ sauveur qu'est ce
qui va se passer ce soir racontez nous
vos
bons soir pierre effectivement un grand
nombre de russes orthodoxes iront cette
nuit et demain matin à l'église pour
célébrer noël face à cette affluence
l'église orthodoxe russe a rappelé
l'importance de respecter les règles
sanitaires l'accès aux églises et aux
monastères sera libre mais le port du
masque et la distanciation sociales
seront obligatoires les lieux de culte
devront en outre être aéré et
désinfecter régulièrement à moscou la
messe donnée dans la cathédrale du
christ sauveur que vous pouvez
effectivement voir derrière moi sera eux
investi uniquement sur invitation mais
sera diffusé sur plusieurs chaînes de
télévision fédérales nombreuses églises
retransmettront par ailleurs leur
cérémonie sur internet comme à son
habitude vladimir poutine assistera à la
messe de minuit dans une église en
dehors de moscou l'an dernier l'épidémie
de covin avait divisé par dix le nombre
de croyants assistant aux offices de
noël entendant malus ont plus d'un
million a célébré à l'église cette
grande fête du calendrier chrétien
beaucoup malice d'estrées en direct de
moscou et vous l'avez dit devant la
cathédrale du christ sauveur merci
beaucoup et bonne soirée